you were good friends with Oprah
Winfrey's she recently there's been this
movement to make what's trying to make
Oprah president you know her do you
think Oprah could be president would she
make a good president well you know
everybody saw the wonderful speech she
gave and I think they responded to the
fact that she has really statesmen like
qualities right I mean she presented
herself well she was very measured very
effective in her speaking and I think
everybody responded to that is you would
expect what people don't know about
Oprah is how well-read she is how well
versed she is on world events and how
really well-prepared she would be for
that job as if she wanted to do it if
she wanted to do it she would really be
actually prepared for it as opposed to
others that might not be prepared for it
I'm not mentioning names right right but
we know who you're talking Terrill for
yeah so but if she if she ran I would
certainly support her now would you do
this because you this is an idea Oprah
as president and then dr. Phil is vice
president I mean would you want to be if
she offered would you be her vice
president well I just talked to her
birthday was just a few days ago and we
were talking and I know I wasn't invited
yeah I think that now I'm never there
yeah I come by a lot yeah pretend to be
the FedEx guy anyway and we were we were
talking about this I just said if you do
become president I want to be ambassador
to Portofino I don't want the whole
country you know what yeah I want
portofino's it was a nice vacation spot
she said she wanted to be an ambassador
for gelato on the beach so I could do
Portofino she would do gelato right you
just both want to have a good time so
that's much commitment is she made
you